AOC declares herself the boss Diane
Feinstein destroys small children and
the Oscars won't stop the politics I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
so I know you're asking Ben how much of
the Oscars did you watch the answer is
zero minutes live because why would I
waste my life like that and if you did
well I'm sorry to say that those are
gonna be minutes you wish you had back
on your deathbed but I'll tell you what
you don't wish you don't wish that you
didn't have gold I mean you know
everyone needs gold because in 2008 the
US national debt was 10 trillion dollars
today the debt is nearly 22 trillion
dollars it is rising like a hockey stick
if you don't think that we are sitting
on a house of cars you're living with
your head in the sand but since you're
listening to my podcast
you're clearly smarter than the average
American so what is your plan can you
afford another hit to your retirement
like the last downturn when the S&P
dropped 50% instead hedge against
inflation and hedge against uncertainty
and instability with some precious
metals gold is a safe haven against
uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified in yours should be as well
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases Birch gold group and right now
thanks to a little-known IRS tax law you
can even move your IRA or eligible 401k
into an IRA back my physical gold and
silver is perfect for people who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from any future geopolitical
uncertainty look back historically when
the bottom falls out of everything else
Gold does tend to safeguard savings
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews and a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau contact Birch
gold group get a free information kit on
physical precious metal see if
diversifying into gold and silver makes
sense for you again and get that
comprehensive 16-page kit all you have
to do is text Ben to 47 47 47 text my
name Ben - 47 47 47 to get that
comprehensive 16 page kit complimentary
Ben - 47 47 47 alrighty so we'll get
into the Oscars in a little bit suffice
it to say I was not supremely surprised
by any of the choices except for
Bohemian Rhapsody for Best editing
clever guys solid joke solid joke
everyone well done
I appreciate the sense of humor but
we'll get to the Oscars and its usual
display of stupidity and over-the-top
over the top
flashes of wealth that AOC and Bernie
will have nothing to say about in any
case let's begin with the green New Deal
so over the weekend something amusing
happen the amusing thing was that AOC
basically lets spill unfortunately what
too many folks on the left actually
think about the uses of government power
now remember ALC came into Congress as a
fresh face you remember so fresh
face incredible freshness as well as
faceless and when she joined she was the
voice of the people
she was the Tribune of the people she
was going to be the new voice of an
underclass that had been
underrepresented for so long she was
certainly not gonna be someone who tried
to centralize power in herself she was
someone who only stood with the
population she's the person who stood
with the downtrodden well she spoke over
the weekend at the New York Hall of
Science and there she suggested that
she's put forward a path in the green
New Deal and if you don't have a better
path in the green New Deal well then she
should become dictator basically here's
what he had to say I just introduced
green New Deal two weeks ago and it's
creating all of this conversation why
because no one else has even tried
because no one else has even tried so
people are like oh it's unrealistic
oh it's vague oh it doesn't address this
little minut thing and I'm like you try
you do it right cuz you're not cuz
you're not so until you do it I'm the
boss okay um number one I know a person
who says that he's the boss Awad
it's my two-year-old son he says it a
lot he says I'm the boss he is not the
boss in point of fact he is a
two-year-old also I love when she says
things like people have questions like
over this little minut detail or that
little minut detail no no we have some
we have some questions about you know
the destruction of the American economy
the slaughtering of all the cows the end
of air travel perhaps the retrofitting
or destruction of every building in the
United States if you want to classify
those as minor questions I'm sure you
could do that I mean I guess that's a
thing also I will note that it's sort of
hilarious when she's like until I got
here nobody ever heard of the
environment until I was sitting here
nobody had ever heard of this thing
called the earth it's a big ball it's
bends in space and it's got an
environment on it and I'm the only
person who ever said anything so if you
haven't said anything about the
environment well then I'm the boss now
and Ed Markey the senator and from
Massachusetts who co-sponsored the green
New Deal said you know like oh what it
happened here longer new lady you got
here five seconds ago
is she really unaware that the Democrats
have been pushing cap-and-trade
legitimately like a dozen years at this
point but I guess she is because she is
not a particularly smart person people
were making this comparison over the
weekend it seems kind of fitting AOC is
basically the cash male side girl from
dr. Phil you do it in all laughing Lysol
funny she's talked about the audience
laughing at her dude did you say that
laughing yeah
so the audience our budget well I guess
that we have a new Congress person so
that's exciting
cash math side girl our future president
when she's president in 2060
end global warming I mean the entire
world will explode because she'll start
a nuclear war or something but that's
that's very exciting stuff
now what was kind of amazing about this
is that what you get from AOC is that
she's number one very irritated by
criticism anybody who criticizes
anything she ever says she cannot take
and number two she really wants the
power for a lady who again came into
Congress on the wave of this populist
uprising she really wants a lot of power
I'm the boss and if you don't agree with
me well then I'm the boss she said
online and sort of the same thing she
tweeted out well if you haven't come up
with a more bold ambitious plan than I
have then I guess I'm the boss now and I
tweeted back I meant listen to last
Friday's show I gave you a bold
ambitious plan it was to bomb China and
India and destroy all of their coal
facilities it's bold
admittedly not not the best plan but
better than yours cuz Italy stop climate
change presumably so I guess I'm the
boss now now let's all be real we all
know who the real boss is it's Tony
Danza but if we but all of this is so
insane
I love Nancy Pelosi just has to be
sitting with her head in her hands every
day over the fact that this person has
somehow grabbed the headlines from her
and Nancy Pelosi by the way is bein in
in Dark Knight Rises she's sitting there
going through fear in control to AOC
because ALC actually has no control ALC
actually has no power Nancy Pelosi is in
charge of all the things a oh she
brought up her green new deal it didn't
even get a vote in the house which is
controlled by the Democrats so no she is
not the boss but it does demonstrate
full scale how for people like AOC power
is absolutely intoxicating incredibly
intoxicating and one of the beautiful
things about power means you never have
to answer serious questions so there's a
piece in the new york post about AOC
today talking about the fact that it's
very possible that she does not even
live in her neighborhood though the one
that she suggests she lives in where
she's a member of the people where she
actually lives right now is in the Navy
Yard in Washington DC one of the most
upscale places in Washington DC paid for
by the way because of a public-private
project to build Washington Nationals
Park the kind of project that she didn't
like with Amazon in any case the New
York Post has a long piece saying that
they were trying to figure out exactly
where she lives in New York like does
she even live in her own district and
her people refused to answer where she
lives she says for safety reasons but
they're not asking for her home address
all they're asking is does she live in
the district she says she lives in and
they won't answer the question the post
emailed Ocasio Cortez's spokesman corbin
trent four times with specific questions
which were all ignored on saturday the
post reached corbin by phone we will not
be commenting he said among the queries
he refused to answer where does the
congresswoman live on Saturday night
a staffer promised a post reporter that
Ocasio Cortez would talk to him after
speaking event in Corona during the
event two staffers were seen reading an
early edition of this story on their
phones come downstairs I have to take a
picture quick the congresswoman then
told the reporter after the event
instructing him to wait for her 20
minutes later she ducked down a back
door jumped into a chauffeured SUV and
zoomed off group gone but don't worry
she's the boss Ocasio Cortez was in New
York City last weekend and this weekend
with appearances in Queens on both
Saturdays it she was not seen coming or
going from her Parkchester pad either
day her apartments next door neighbor
said she had never seen no Casa Cortez
another neighbor was lived down the hall
from the congresswoman's apartment for
the last 40 years said she'd never seen
her or her boyfriend Riley Roberts who
has claimed the addresses his own since
last spring I would have remembered said
the neighborhood shown a photograph of
AOC workers at Jerry's pizzeria less
than a block from her building and at
the local grocery store she'd said she
had never patronized their businesses
and a server at a nearby
Correa said the congresswoman had only
come in to be filmed by news crews a
postal worker who delivers mail to the
building said that in the last 10 years
he has only seen Ocasio Cortez
intermittently and that several months
worth of mail regularly accumulates in
the mailbox before anyone bothers to
collect it the worker said that Ocasio
Cortez and Roberts were the only ones
getting mail at the address he said just
because their names are on the box
doesn't mean they live there and in 2017
when Ocasio Cortez first filed paperwork
to become a congressional candidate she
didn't even know what district she lived
in mistakenly declaring plans to run for
a neighboring district 15 before
correcting the day the error days later
her new digs over in the Navy Yard
feature gold-plated amenities like a
rooftop infinity pool a cycling studio
with a dozen pricey peloton's men's and
women's saunas a golf simulation lounge
but no affordable units for low-income
residents in spite of a local law that
requires them the news site reported
that Washington Examiner reported so so
much for all of this apparently once
again Ocasio Cortez not being clear
about her own personal behavior but the
good news is she's the boss now what's
hilarious about all of this is what
makes her the boss is that she says
catastrophic things on a regular basis I
mean stuff that is just steeped in
catastrophic thinking so for example AOC
talks about climate change in the way
she talks about climate change is the
same way a small trial to talk about
climate change I say the same way a
small child talks about climate change
because in just a few minutes I'm going
to play your audio of a small child
talking about climate change and it's
indistinguishable from a OC
indistinguishable except for the timbre
of the voice
so AOC said over the weekend that
Republicans won't have to deal with
climate change because after all they'll
all be dead
which is weird because she's like six
years younger than I am and I speak
regularly to thousands of Republicans
who are younger than she is but
apparently all the Republicans will be
dead so they won't have to deal with
climate change she will have to deal
with climate change I'm 29 and I know
that this is gonna be the world that
we're gonna have to deal with that we're
gonna have to live in and with all due
respect to my colleagues but especially
in like the Republican Party it's like
you're not gonna have to live with this
problem you're just I'm sorry
ie you're too old
I mean no bones but seriously Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer are 1,000 years
old
the average Democratic leader is older
than the average Republican leader so
she's just saying nonsense at this point
but again all of this is catastrophic
nonsense and you know Rahm Emanuel who
is chief of staff for Barack Obama once
said never let a good crisis go to waste
so now Democrats are manufacturing
massive crises massive crack world's
shaking end of world all humans will die
crises so that they can say I'm the boss
that's really what this is about
AOC is merely a miniature of what her
party is if we pretend that the problem
is so looming and so big and so
disastrous but not disastrous enough for
us to do anything practical like you
know build nuclear power plants but so
big and so disastrous that we have to
wreck the entire economy on the shoals
of this problem well then I guess that
you'll have to give us all the power I
mean that makes me the boss doesn't it
in a second we'll get to that that
wasn't these were not even her dumbest
statements of the weekend wait until you
hear what else she had to say about the
green New Deal first let's talk about
stamps.com no one really has time to go
to the post office you're busy who has
time for the traffic parking lugging all
your mail and packages it's a real
hassle which is why you need stamps calm
it's one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps calm
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts you
cannot even get at the post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices
and online sellers shipping out products
or even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages per day stamps comm can handle
it all with ease you can simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it ed
with stamps comm you get five cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail stamps comm is a
no-brainer it saves you time and money
which is why I personally use stamps
comm to make sure I don't have to schlep
my stuff down to the post office and to
make sure that I'm saving money on my
postage right now my listeners get a
special offer it includes a four week
trial plus free postage and the digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Shapiro that stamps comm
enter Shapiro to make sure that you get
that special deal four-week trial plus
free postage you and the digital scale
an awesome trial go check it out stamps
comm click on the mic at the top of the
home page type in Shapiro all right so a
OC is so catastrophic and/or thinking
because the bigger the catastrophe the
more government
while we need this is how things match
up why do you think the Democrats like
talking about world war two because you
know what happened during the world war
two a vast government seizure of pretty
much everything in the United States
goods were rationed prices were
controlled wages were controlled all the
men were put in barracks and given
rations if this was your ideal for how
to build an economy I would say that
you've got some real thinking to do
about liberty and freedom but the bigger
you can make the catastrophe the more
power you're able to seize now it's
amazing because Democrats will suggest
that President Trump is doing this with
the border they'll say that he's
manufacturing a crisis at the border and
therefore he is seizing executive power
in order to build a wall that is nothing
compared to what Democrats are trying to
do with the green New Deal and the issue
of climate change in just a second I'm
going to show you what a OC had to say
about this because it's really insane
again you have to maximize the damage
climate change is going to do and the
the extremity of how bad things are
going to get and how quickly they're
going to get in order so that you can
grab power in the here and now so here
is a OC suggesting that we will all die
literally we'll all die if we don't pass
her green New Deal we're screwed
if we do nothing there is no hope there
is a global threat to the planet a
global threat and at this point we don't
even have to prove it just walk outside
in winter in a lot of places and it's
either way worse than you're used to or
way warmer than you're used to
hurricanes storms wildfires we are dying
now we are dying that what what world is
she living in and just a question
does she know any history at all the
average life expectancy in the United
States is 80 years old 80 people over
the centuries would have killed to have
that life expectancy everyone was dying
at like 35 150 years ago what is she
even talking about she's sitting in a
she's sitting in like a top-notch
apartment in Washington DC slicing
squash and putting it in a blender on
Instagram and talking about how we're
all going
to die and the world is over and and you
don't even have to provide evidence all
you have to do is walk outside really
you seem pretty comfortable there aoc it
seems like you're kind of living through
this thing
I mean could you such bravery such
toughness living through this thing well
instagramming hair instant pot cooking
unbelievable I mean whoo the coolness
under fire
that's what's truly impressive is that
she knows if she walked outside she'd be
dead in a second because of the freezing
cold temperatures or because of the
massive heat wave thanks to global
warming that is happening in the here
and now so bad that she says she does
not even have to prove that it's going
to happen in the future
or that her plans are going to do
anything to mitigate it that's how bad
it is because people are dying it's all
over everybody freaked out oh and by the
way here's my great recipe for a squash
kugel
it that it's just this in genuine it's
obviously disingenuous it is clearly and
obviously disingenuous and then it gets
even better she says not only are we all
going to die maybe we shouldn't have
kids
we'll listen aoc if you want to be the
first to start with this I'm fine with
that frankly I don't think that if
you're going to indoctrinate your kids
into believing that they are on the
verge of their doom then please don't
like please don't all these for you I'm
not gonna have kids cuz the environment
is so scary out there again now is a
better time to live than any time in
human history
life expectancy around the world has
never been higher poverty rates have
never been lower what are you even
talking about what are you saying
but here's aoc encouraging young people
not to have babies because it's hot
outside or something there's scientific
consensus that the lives of children are
going to be very difficult and it does
lead I think young people to have a
legitimate question you know should is
it okay to still have children and I
mean not just financially because people
are graduating with 2030 a hundred
thousand dollars for this
loans at and so they can't even afford
to have kids in the house but also just
this basic moral question like what do
we do and and even if you don't have
kids there are still children here in
the world and we have a moral obligation
to them and to leave a better world for
them is it okay to still have children
okay if you're taking your moral advice
on life from a 29 year old bartender
turned congresswoman who is not married
and doesn't have kids if that's if
that's where you're gonna get your moral
advice all you man go for it
seriously I hope you do I hope you do if
you're a kind of person who thinks this
is intelligent commentary from AOC then
I hope you live out all of her
prescriptions and don't have kids
because what the hell it's just it's
inane it's in name nonsense but it's a
name nonsense that is directed at full
scale alarmism so that you can grab more
power that's all this is about it's all
it was always about now what's hilarious
about this is I said earlier that she
speaks like a small child on these
issues I said that advisedly when I say
she speaks like a small child I mean
literally like a small child my favorite
video of the last few days there are a
bunch of kids from something called the
sunrise movement and they've been
indoctrinated by their teachers and by
their parents to believe that they are
on the verge of their own death which
they are not okay again the United
States is the safest most prosperous
healthiest country that has ever been
that has ever been the only possible
exceptions are in Western Europe which
we prop up with our economy and yet
these kids are going to Diane
Feinstein's office and trying to lecture
her about climate change now I tweeted
out this clip if this doesn't make you
love Diane Feinstein I don't know it
well I've despised Diane Feinstein as my
senator for years like I don't know her
as a lady maybe she's a nice lady I
don't know but as a senator I've thought
she's terrible for years and for
literally my entire life because she's
been a senator since I was like eight
years old in the state of California and
I'm now 35 so she's been around for a
long time in the state of California but
with all of that said watch how she an
adult deals with children on climate
change and it's pretty fantastic we are
trying to ask you to vote YES on the
green New Deal
okay I'll tell you what we have our own
green New Deal scientists have said that
we have 12 years to turn this around
well it's not going to get turned around
in ten years what we can do just doesn't
in ten years you're looking at the faces
of the people who are going to be living
with one of the people by the people and
what's interesting about this group
isn't I've been doing this for thirty
years I know what I'm doing you come in
here and you say it has to be my way or
the highway I don't respond to that yes
thank you and adults okay I don't even
agree with Dianne Feinstein on policy
but thank you for the love of God
and now please somebody go say that to
aoc somebody goes say listen I'm an
adult I've been doing this for a while
sit down you don't know what you're
talking about let's just stop just stop
say whatever you want you know do your
stupid Instagram vegetarian chili
cooking do whatever you want but if you
are gonna pretend that you're the boss
and come the hell odd so good on Dianne
Feinstein owning the small shows one of
the facts in logic now if she will only
turn to these small children within her
own party the mental the mental
derelicts inside her own party who
apparently have no compunction about
saying completely fact with things who
are not interested in real solutions who
simply want to primp and pose so that
they can get on the covers of magazines
and then take more power for themselves
so that they can be the boss okay then
Dianne Feinstein's step in Nancy Pelosi
step in honest-to-goodness you want to
make sure your party doesn't collapse
into the dust because I don't think most
Americans resonate to this at some point
you're gonna have to tell the children
to shut up at some point gonna have to
tell the children that they don't know
what they are talking about more that
they don't know what they're talking
about then to shut up let them honestly
from a Republican point of view from a
conservative point of you keep talking
weight speak amongst yourselves and in
front of the cameras please do this
meanwhile we're gonna get to Kamala
Harris the democratic presumed
frontrunner maybe in just one second
first let's talk about something we can
all agree on saving money we can all
agree that getting the best deal is
important when shopping online you've
probably heard me talk about honey the
amazing free browser extension that
automatically helps me save
on all my favourite sites but I would
not be doing my job if I didn't tell you
about how honey makes even Amazon better
how so you ask well let me explain with
millions of sellers on Amazon selling
the same products how do you know you're
really getting the best price you don't
unless you use honey as you shop on
Amazon
honey's best price finder automatically
compares the prices of millions of
sellers that carry the item you want
honey even factors in shipping sales tax
and Amazon Prime status to make sure
that you are getting the lowest total
price I use honey I haven't running the
background of my computer so that I can
get the best deals whenever I shop at
Amazon I'm a huge Amazon customer just
the other day we save significant buku
dollars on a set of weights that I
bought for myself and my wife because
we're finally getting into the fitness
so go check it out right now at honey
it's join honey calm / Ben next time
you're shopping on Amazon treat yourself
to that free upgrade add honey for free
and join honey dot-com / Ben that is
join honey calm / Ben honey is the smart
shopping assistant that helps you save
time and money join honey calm / been
already meanwhile as the Democratic
Party slides ever to the left Kamala
Harris has tried to leap to the front of
the pack now in all of the polls she is
not quite doing that she has the
momentum she has more momentum than say
Elizabeth Warren who is I guess fading
out into the colors of the wind but
Kamala Harris is still trailing Bernie
Sanders because Bernie Sanders has what
all the young people are looking for a
bag full of crazy and some old people
charm Kamala Harris is trying the
intersectional approach so Kamala Harris
basically is taking the Oscars approach
to politics so I knew what was gonna
that green book was gonna win last night
at the Oscars how did I know the Green
Book was gonna win last night at the
Oscars because I knew the shape of water
was probably gonna win the year before
why did I know that because I have a
very simple algorithm that I use for the
Oscars these simple algorithm that I use
for the Oscars is is simply I just look
at the PC metric on particular in the
intersectional metric on particular
movies so last night nominated for
Oscars in the Best Picture categories
where Bohemian Rhapsody a movie about a
gay guy the favorite a movie about an
old lesbian black panther a movie about
black folks black Klansmen a movie about
black folks vais a movie about Dick
Cheney which was gonna go nowhere a star
is born a movie about straight white
people going nowhere
Roma a story about a Latina woman
and greenbook a story about a black gay
guy obvious what's gonna win right
I mean Kokomo Harris is basically doing
the same thing but in the 2020
Democratic primaries she's basically
saying listen there's there's a lot of
women in this primary and there's some
black people in this primary but do you
have a black woman in this primary and
if the answer is no well honey I got an
answer for you right here
that's comely Harris's campaign and she
is basically saying it out loud that's
what's so astonishing so she came out
yesterday and she says you know people
keep complaining about this identity
politics stuff she's referring to Bernie
because Bernie has said that identity
politics is a bad idea generally that we
should judge candidates based on their
merits not based on their race or their
sex Kamala Harris has to fight back
against that because that's basically
the only reason she is in the race she's
a first term senator from California she
has not done a thing anything
the only reason anyone is discussing her
Rover's say even Amy Klobuchar is
because Kamala Harris happens to be a
black woman so she has to somehow fight
back on the idea that identity politics
is bad so here she is explaining
identity politics is actually good this
term identity politics people will use
that term it's like the people used to
talk about the race car right and
they'll bring this term up when you talk
about issues that are about race about
sexual orientation about religion
they'll bring it up when we're talking
about civil rights issues as a way to
marginalize the issue as a way to
frankly try to silence you or shut you
up okay I love this so much because what
identity politics itself is is a way to
silence and shut up and so now if you
say identity politics is bad then you
are the person shutting people up here
is why identity politics shuts people up
the way identity politics works is it it
makes in a central claim the essential
claim that it makes is that you and I
cannot understand each other if we are
members of different racial groups or
different ethnic groups or different
sexual groups that if I am a white man I
can therefore not understand what you a
black woman are saying kamo Harris
there's no meeting of the minds there's
no actual logic that allows us to speak
beyond our own personal identity and
thus if you say something I say listen
that's wrong you say listen that's my
truth and you don't have the capacity to
challenge my truth all I can do is
appeal to my own in-group and if you
don't respect then my in-group has
authority on the
issue then you are not respecting
identity politics you're not respecting
my identity in fact if you disagree with
my politics then you are disagreeing
with my identity it makes you bad you're
a racist this is how you get from I
disagree with Kamala Harris - I'm a
racist right that's how you get from one
to the other the idea being that Kamala
Harris's politics are rooted in her
identity if I disagree with her politics
I therefore don't understand or I'm
afraid of her identity and therefore
have attacked her identity and therefore
I am discriminating against her simply
by virtue of disagreeing identity
politics is a way of destroying common
conversation that's what it is Western
civilization was built on the notion we
are all individuals freely capable of
using our reason to communicate with one
another all of liberal republicanism is
based on this I mean like a liberal
Republic a free republic all of it is
based on the idea that we are able to
overcome our own membership in in
particular groups and speak to each
other as individuals capable of using
human reason identity politics cuts
directly against that but Kamala Harris
wants to be able to run on the basis of
identity politics so now she says that
if I call out her identity politics if
for example I say that she's pandering
on particular issues because she's
trying to pander to particular political
groups that she thinks will benefit her
when she says that she's four for
example slavery reparations when I say
that this is obviously a move to try and
gain black votes in the Democratic
primaries in 2020 because that's the
only group in America that
overwhelmingly supports slavery
reparations and so that is an aspect of
her invoking politics of identity in
order to garner certain votes back if I
say that then that's me attempting to
shut her up now that's silly because I'm
more than willing to have a conversation
about the relative merits and demerits
of slavery reparations we did it twice
last week on the show but her point is
that if you challenge anything she has
to say then you are by nature
challenging her identity and that's the
only way she's gonna get through these
primaries you know maybe it works too
many Democrats have bought into this but
it is an ugly way of doing politics and
once again it demonstrates that Kamala
Harris's biggest selling point is in
fact her identity and not actually her
capacity to be a good senator or to do
anything of use this should be obvious
from another answer she gave yesterday
in the same interview she was asked
specifically about the cost of all of
her various programs on MSNBC with joy
Reid who by the way how does Drive
so have a show question how does Joey
Reed still have a show didn't she have
like a bunch of old homophobic posts and
then she pretended that she didn't write
them and then she was hacked and then
her web said and somehow she saw the job
probably for the same reason Ralph
Northam still has a job anyway Harris
was making the rounds she was on Joey
Reed and then I guess she was also on
CNN with John King and she was asked
specifically about how she was gonna pay
for all of her bizarro world Medicare
for all free college for all everything
free for everybody proposals and she
gave the same answer that AOC gave which
is when money grows on trees and I'm the
boss can we afford it two and a half
three trillion dollars a year for
Medicare for all by some studies I don't
depending on which portions of the green
new do you pick to do first that's money
that you know what the Republicans are
going to say tax-and-spend liberals
pie-in-the-sky one of the things that I
admire and respect is the measurement
that is captured in three letters ROI
what's the return on the investment
people in the private sector understand
this really well it's not about a cost
it's about an investment and then the
question should be is it worth the cost
in terms of the investment potential are
we gonna get back more than we put in
okay if she is really suggesting that
there is an ROI a return on investment
that's the term we use in the private
sector for what she's talking about
first of all she's not investing her own
dollar she's investing my dollars in
your dollar second of all there is no
ROI on what she is talking about right
now there's an ROI on the dollars that I
personally spend on my health care how
do I know because I'm paying for it what
is the ROI on her grabbing two to three
trillion dollars out of the American
economy and allocating it through
government resources and whenever
somebody if somebody ever asks you know
how much is this gonna cost they say you
don't don't worry about it just look at
the benefit just look at the upside
they're selling you something she's
selling you something and what she's
selling you it ain't great okay well
we're gonna discuss more on Kamala
Harris plus we have to get to Venezuela
where Democrats are still struggling to
condemn it and the Oscars right we still
got to get to today but you have to go
check us out at Daley wire.com also make
sure to join us tonight for daily we're
backstage or we'll be talking about
everyone's favorite award show that's
cynical I hope daily wire god-king
Jeremy boring me and Roy Clavin the
execrable Michael Mills and Alicia Kraus
will be here talking culture Hollywood
and of course taking your questions as
always only daily wire subscribers gets
to ask those questions so make sure
that you go subscribe today also I have
some exciting news thanks to you the
fans daily wire is currently going
through a growth spurt and has several
positions newly open that we are
actually looking to fill so if you want
to work here that's the thing you can do
head on over to daily wire.com slash
jobs to check out what positions are
available see how you can become a
member of the daily wire team again that
is daily wire comm slash jobs go check
it out today make sure that you
subscribe for $9.99 a month so you can
be part of the daily wire backstage
tonight also $99 0 gets you that's the
very greatest in all beverage vessels
leftist here's how to recall tumblr gaze
upon it in despair that you have not one
go check it out
right now we have all sorts of goodies
coming up for you we have Sundays
specials coming up for you we're going
to be doing more in the mail bag we have
two hours in a day additionally that
you're not seeing if you're not actually
a member over at daily wire we do that
later in the afternoon so I'll be back
later I spend my entire day slaving away
at this job for you people so make sure
that you go subscribe right now daily
wire comm go check us out we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so Kamala Harris look maybe she wins on
the intersectional appeal maybe she does
but I don't think there's a lot there
other than the intersectional appeal
because other than that she's basically
just doing a warmed-over Bernie routine
her strongest case for why she should be
nominated she says we need someone to
prosecute the case against Trump do you
really think there's any shortage of
people in the Democratic Party willing
to say bad things about Trump that's
pretty much all they have in common at
this point
here's Kamala Harris though suggesting
that she's gonna prosecute Trump
properly we're gonna need somebody who
knows how to prosecute the case against
this president okay I just don't know
why that's enough appeal like as opposed
to every other Democrat who wants to
prosecute the case against the president
all right then I guess meanwhile things
have collapsed over in Venezuela where
it looks like open turmoil is is the
latest situation this has not stopped
some Democrats from coming out in
defense of the current Venezuelan regime
or at least in lukewarm fashion for the
Venezuelan regime there's an amazing
tweet thread from Chris Murphy who is
believe it or not an actual United
States Senator from from Connecticut he
tweeted out over the weekend Democrats
need to be careful about a potential
trap being set by Trump at all in
Venezuela okay we can stop right there
for a second first of all the potential
trap being set by Trump if you look at
Venezuela and you think the problem is
Trump you got another thing coming the
problem in Venezuela is a socialist
government run by a socialist dictator
who is in fully socialist fashion
murdering his people and preventing
human aid from getting in preventing any
sort of food or water from getting in
through particular borders Chris Murphy
says cheering humanitarian convoys
sounds like the right thing to do but
what if it's not about the aid so now
he's arguing a full United States
Senator is arguing against humanitarian
convoys for people who are eating dogs
children are dying in Venezuela and
we're being told by Chris Murphy we
should worry about Trump he says what if
the real agenda is laying a pretext for
war follow my logic for a second first
so secret Trump has been talking up
laureth Maduro since 2017 when he
repeatedly asked McMaster for a plan to
overthrow Maduro noumic a book confirms
now Trump says all options are on the
table and Rubio objects to Senate
resolution that forbids war okay first
of all you know you used to say all
options were on the table a lot a
president in Barack Obama he said with
regard to Iran with whom he was secretly
attempting to cut a nuclear deal leaving
Iran in control of
weaponry and more money so that's always
been part of American policy the idea
that behind the velvet glove lays an
iron fist or the possibility thereof
that's nothing new but I mean do you
really think Trump wants to go to war in
Venezuela you think that's really
something Trump is up for Chris Murphy
continues though he says I wanted to get
to Venezuelans but let's be honest
Venezuela didn't just lurch into
humanitarian crisis the eight is being
sent there now as part of regime change
strategy many are hoping that it will be
the match that lights a civil war
against Maduro the civil war against
Maduro is already taking place dude
there are hundreds of thousands of
people in the streets some are being
shot by the active military they're
trying to recruit the military over to
their own side I guess being a Democrat
means they are more worried about Donald
Trump than you are about Nicolas Maduro
it's an amazing thing
Murphy says senator Rubio rushed to
tweet out reports today of Maduro allies
firing into Colombian territory warning
that the United States will help
Colombia confront any aggression against
them Venezuela ordered Colombian
diplomats out in 24 hours ramping up the
crisis by the way Rubio also tweeted out
the two expatriate members of the
Venezuelan National Assembly were
poisoned in Colombia yesterday
presumably by the by the Maduro
government Maduro is evil finally I love
that this takes still tweet 5 Maduro is
evil and the United States should pursue
a strategy to undermine him and prompt
new elections but no one can no one can
defend but what he has done in Venezuela
but it's quite a different thing for the
u.s. to incite a civil war with no real
plan for how it ends sound familiar well
yeah it does sound familiar didn't your
boss do that didn't Barack Obama do that
back during the Libyan war when some of
us were saying I'm bad idea dude and he
did it repeatedly during the Arab Spring
when some of us were saying bad idea
Murphy concludes finally perhaps most
importantly go look up the 1947 Rio
treaty it's a Western Hemisphere mutual
defense treaty and may not require a war
declaration if Trump is legitimately
coming to the defense of Colombia don't
think the Venezuela Hawks don't know
this again Donald Trump does not want to
go to war in Venezuela and he does not
want to be expending American blood and
treasure in Venezuela but we are going
to support the Venezuelan people every
way short of war if we can and will
support Colombia with presumably
military aid if they need it against the
Venezuelan government if you're a
Democrat and your chief worry today is
about America's war and about Trump and
how volatile E is and not the fact that
Maduro is doing all the stuff again
there's been no
indicator from the Trump administration
they are interested in going to war none
none an egg and once again
administration's signal routinely every
single one Democrat and Republican they
are always signaling that they are
willing to go to the ultimate if they
have to but there's been no indicator
that Trump actually wants to do that and
it's amazing to watch Democrats come out
of the woodwork to try and defend Maduro
in effect even as they pretend that they
really don't like Maduro very much okay
meanwhile the Oscars took place last
night and it was exactly what you would
think it was it was a it was a liberal
self-pleasuring fest it was ridiculous
in in every possible way first of all
nobody had seen any of these movies
except for Bohemian Rhapsody and Black
Panthers so two of the movies people saw
but human Rhapsody won a bunch of awards
including for best film editing which is
just I mean as I said early on the show
solid prank everyone for those who
actually saw Bohemian Rhapsody or
Eclipse from Bohemia absentee
essentially the way that that film was
edited is that they had several cameras
running on the same scene and then they
had a monkey with the toggle switch who
just toggled between reaction shots that
meant nothing it's one of the worst
edited films of all time and won best
film editing because guess what people
in Hollywood don't know anything about
movies or these quality of movies in any
case the Oscars are always a back
patting fest and it's there's always a
large helping of irony when the folks
who are most concerned about income
inequality and who are cheering Bernie
Sanders and Kamala Harris walk in with
thirty million dollar diamonds around
their neck I'm not kidding Lady gaga
were a 30 million dollar 128 karat
diamonds at the Oscars last night she
cares about the people guys she's really
in touch with the people I always find
it amazing how AOC finds time to rip on
Jeff Bezos who is created legitimately
hundreds of thousands of jobs but never
finds any time at all to go after you
know some of the some of the major
celebrities who are walking around
wearing $10,000 gowns they were they
will wear once and then discard on the
charity pile it's pretty incredible the
most celebrated gown of the evening by
the way was worn by somebody named Billy
Porter I don't know who the hell Billy
Porter is have you had any you guys have
ever heard of Billy Porter I'd never
heard of this guy so this was just an
attention gathering thing so this this
guy walks onto the onto the red carpet
wearing a tuxedo
gown like a full-on ballroom gown with a
it sounds like a hoop skirt with like a
trail and people like oh so brave brave
and stunning stunning and brave bravery
mix stuns a lot it's just like Normandy
the bravery ah magnificent now forgive
me but dudes wearing gowns on a on a
carpet on a red carpet mm maybe I missed
it I mean maybe I'm missing Lee the
great joy that is to be had from the
dudes wearing gowns on a red carpet but
honestly I actually think it's an actual
issue for the country not because I
think it's very important I don't think
it's very important but I do think that
the attempt by the media to conflate
male with female and to pretend that
males acting in stereotypically female
ways does not have any impact on
children and that gender confusion is
actually a good thing and that all of
this is merely a that all gender
distinctions in dress and in manner and
in behavior and in what they wear that
all of these are simply social
constructs of no serious import if
that's true then you're gonna have to
explain why virtually every culture in
the history of the planet has had
separate dress for men and women
very few cultures men and women dress a
dress identically because men and women
are different and the attempts you say
oh well so brave that here's this guy
who's willing to dress like a woman
question why is it cultural
appropriation when a white chick wears a
kimono but it is not cultural
appropriation when a black male wear is
a stereotypically female dress and
historically a female dress there is no
answer to this because it makes no sense
of course this was of course not the
only silly thing that happened at the
Oscars there was lots of silliness at
the Oscars so at the very beginning
President Trump got mocked over the wall
now I will note there were a couple of
names that were not mentioned the entire
Oscars telecast so far as I know one of
the names was Bryan Singer the director
of Bohemian Rhapsody was amazing it won
an Oscar after Oscar in a bunch of
categories the director is kind of
responsible for now one person think
Bryan Singer because he's under
suspicion of having statutorily raped
underage boys so nobody was willing to
mention Bryan Singer's that's one name
that didn't get mentioned the other name
that didn't even get joked about his
jussie Smollett it's only the leading
story in America and it's about an actor
in Hollywood faking a hoax crime faking
a hate crime
now one mentioned at the Oscars last
night but plenty of mentions of Trump
because brave stunning stunning brave
brave mix tons stunning MacRay 'very it
if you think that it is brave for people
in Hollywood to get up in front of other
people in Hollywood and make jokes about
Donald Trump let me introduce you to
like anyone who is brave on planet earth
because any one of those people is
braver than what just happened last
night so here all these women dumping
like legitimate bad jokes for the forget
about going after Trump every president
can be made fun of except Obama we don't
make fun of them but all the other
presidents we can make fun of and that's
fine I'm just wondering why this is a
funny joke so here are the the leading
women of Hollywood this is Tina Fey and
Amy Poehler and I can never and Maya
Rudolph thank you I making jokes about
drum everybody confused there is no host
tonight there won't be a popular movie
category and Mexico is not paying for
the wall why is that a joke how was that
even close to a joke there's just that
she could have made the same joke this
way she could have said just a quick
update in case you're confused there is
no host tonight there won't be a popular
movie category and we all hate
Republicans yeah so much so much talent
in that room my goodness then Javier
Bardem got up and condemned borders and
walls he did this in Spanish so that
nobody in America who doesn't speak
Spanish can understand him there he was
doing that last night that can restrain
ingenuity and talent and Trump's like
wait until you see mine said in any
region of any country of any continent
there are always great stories then
tonight we celebrate the excellence and
importance of the cultures and languages
of different kind is the best foreign
language category that's fine that's all
fine but I love these they're no borders
and walls can restrain ingenuity and
talent how about this alligator moat
check this check this out it's like
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom and
believe BA it it's so tiring honestly
it's so tiring and it's tiresome more
than tiring it's tiresome and then chef
Jose
gets up and he says we owe compassion to
the invisible people the invisible
people like immigrants immigrants are
not invisible in the United States we
all know many of them my wife is an
immigrant like just stop just stop
you're boring in broma Alfonso Cuaron
presents an honest and vital portrait of
the Mexico City of this childhood a
place full of contrasts and
contradictions but love is where
everyone meets and these beautiful
intimate film one that gives a voice to
the voiceless reminds us of the
understanding and compassion that we all
owe the invisible people in our lives
immigrants okay I just have to point out
right here Romo is so boring yeah I know
I know it's not really on topic I mean
it is a little they mentioned roma Roma
is death on wheels yeah I've watched the
first 25 minutes and I thought to myself
there was a four minute establishing
shot of water running over cobblestones
stop it just stop and so the Oscars did
what the Oscars do and they do the same
thing every year and they are always
equally irritating people always like
why are you irritated by the Oscars well
because you put out a program that's
supposed to be the best of one of
America's seminal domestic industries
and all you can come up with is the
latest PC films that nobody saw and then
make fun of whatever Republicans happen
to be in office while feeding in
whatever Democrats happen to be in
office you want to do something honestly
if the Oscars want to do something
different they should have a Republican
host them then it would actually be
entertaining and fun like roast
Hollywood that's by the way they used to
do this like even Bob Hope when he was
hosting the Oscars for years and years
and years he would always start off by
roasting Hollywood because we all loved
Hollywood we all like going to the
movies but these people deserve to be
roasted a little bit don't they don't
they okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today over the
weekend I was reading a book by Michael
Denton who is in fact a biologist called
evolution still a theory in crisis the
the book does not suggest that evolution
does not take place of course the book
is basically about how micro evolution
takes place but he makes the point that
the notion that natural selection
combined with genetic mutation the idea
that this has provided for all change in
human history and that macro-evolution
meaning the jump from species to species
that that is simply a result of natural
selective pressure combined with
mutations there's just not enough
evidence for that so macro evolution and
micro evolution might actually run along
different lines and you'd be surprised
to learn how many major biologists and
scientists agree with them people
including folks like Stephen Jay Gould
that the notion that evolution is a
continuous slow process of incremental
change and that that has taken us from
species to species that's not really
accurate just biologically speaking
there's evolution within species there's
evolution over time but the notion that
you can move from one to the other
without some sort of different factor
making the change happen as opposed to
just random natural selection natural
selection and random mutation that's
essentially what the book is about it's
it's highly technical there's a lot in
there that's technical but the book is
well worth the read Michael Denton's
evolutions still a theory in crisis okay
time for some things that I hate okay so
thing that I hate number one to Nike ran
a commercial last night and everybody
was fawning over this commercial oh look
at this commercial it's all about how
women are victimized in our society
number one there are some women who are
victimized in our society you know who
they aren't prominent athletes prominent
female athletes in our society are not
victims they're earning millions and
millions of dollars to play a sport
that's silly
also if we're gonna talk about people
who are victimized in our society women
are not high on the list women are now
living freer better lives than any
people ever on planet Earth in history
at any time this is this it's just it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous contention in
the same way it's ridiculous when aoc
says we're all moments away from death
it is ridiculous when Nike contends that
women are sorely put upon in the United
States it is simple pandering people
like to be told that they are a victim
of American society most people in the
United States are not victims of
American society listen to this this
silly Nike commercial when we stand for
something where unhinged no
when we're to good there's something
wrong with us and I think it Bhangra
we're his steering okay can we pause it
for a second okay when they say when we
when we are when we stand for something
then we are unhinged really Margaret
Thatcher did people call her and hinged
for standing for something did condi
rice do people call her on hinge for
standing for something women in your
life when they stand strong for
something worth wild we call them
unhinged no we don't and then they say
when we when we outperform and there's
something wrong with us and they show a
picture of a woman named semenya Semenya
actually has a genetic disorder which
means that she as a child and as an
adult has received essentially male
levels of testosterone throughout her
life and that means that she's been able
to out-compete other women on the base
of this was an actual Olympic
controversy so let's not pretend that
there was no genetic abnormality with
Semenya there was a genetic abnormality
with Semenya which is why she was
dominating women in competition I always
say when we get angry than were than
were considered hysterical
well no women get angry on a fairly
regular basis and are not considered
hysterical when you're hysterical we
consider you hysterical just like when
men are hysterical we consider that then
history like what what this whole make
women are so put upon but they can
overcome by this crappy sneaker made by
child slaves in Bangladesh ok I'm not
making actual formal allegations that
they use child slavery in Bangladesh
it's just a rumour guys one of our
producers Austin said that Nike really
should change their slogan not to just
do it but now not all of our shoes
explode it seems about right after what
happened in the Duke North Carolina
basketball game
anyway the rest of this commercial is
similarly silly or just being crazy
but a woman running a marathon was crazy
a woman competing in a good job changing
her sport landing a double cork ten
eighty or winning 23 Grand Slams having
a baby and then coming back for more
crazy crazy and crazy okay goof Sabbath
em for a second literally no one said
that it was crazy for Serena Williams to
compete coming back from a child no not
a human literally no one said it was
crazy for her to win 23 grand slams
except that it's crazy in the sense that
she's amazing at what she does she's the
narrator of this commercial by the way
literally no one says that it is crazy
for Simone biles to compete or for a
woman to compete in a hijab or for a
woman to change sports or for a woman to
flip twice on a snowboard or something
no one says that what are they talking
about
I like they just shifted the notion of
crazy so crazy Moo isn't like the
colloquial sense well that's wild the
dapper that's incredible the person did
that has now been shifted to be the same
thing as they were doubted who doubted
Serena Williams Serena Williams been the
most dominant player in women's tennis
for two decades who doubted Simone biles
anybody who saw her knew what kind of
talent she had this is just it's just
asinine and it's sort of and and then
what's even more kind of saccharine and
sickening is all the men on Twitter like
oh what a beautiful commercial oh what
an incredible complicit guys I know that
you want the ladies to think that you
love that you're that you're sensitive
and kind but come on come on it's a
silly commercial it's a silly commercial
we all want women to be strong we all
want women to be independent we all want
women to be free we all want the same
things for women who is this mysterious
other who's telling women you can't play
tennis you can't compete in a heat like
who's doing this I hate the creation of
false enemies simply so that you can
declare their self the hero which in
fact may be the theme of the show right
me that's what a OC does with global
warming and now it's what Serena
Williams and Nike are doing with this ad
there's a group of nefarious men living
in the shadows telling Serena Williams
she can't play tennis anymore who are
they they don't exist but if they did
they would be telling you not to buy
Nikes so buy Nikes just do it what
absolute silliness okay final thing that
I hate today
Bill Maher said a very very silly thing
over the weekend it is amazing how
people in blue states like to pretend
very often blue state folks they like to
pretend that they are all four people in
red states the downtrodden there are
four people who earn less economically
for lower income there's an enormous
amount of scorn for people in red states
from blue states
people in red states tend not to thing
I've been in a lot of red states
a lot of time there people in red states
do not spend a lot of time thinking
about people in blue states they really
know like people in Texas don't care
about California they just don't want
California coming to Texas people in
people in Indiana don't spend a lot of
time thinking about New York they really
don't like they have their own lives
they have that they have their own
things that they're doing folks in
Tennessee not worried about what's
happening in Massachusetts people in
Massachusetts are deeply worried about
what's happening in Tennessee people in
California are deeply worried about
what's happening in Texas they are
deeply concerned about all of the evil
people in Texas doing what they want to
do and they have to somehow justify to
themselves why it is that they're paying
twice what other people pay for living
where they live and why it is that
people in Texas seem pretty happy
without any of the government
restrictions or social values that folks
on the left want them to have and so you
end up with this bill Mahr here saying
that red states are jealous of blue
states the truth is the other way around
people in blue states are very are very
often jealous of people in red states
because people in red states don't think
about people in blue states all that
much here is Bill Maher though just
sneering at people in in red states
there are two Americas and it seems like
one is where all the cool jobs are where
people drive Tesla's and eat artisanal
ice cream we have orchestras and theater
districts and world-class shopping we
have chef Wolfgang Puck they have Chef
Boyardee Wow Wow okay first of all you
know what else we have in LA like I'm
from the same city as Bill Maher you
know what else we have 70,000 homeless
people on the streets needles in the
open
people crapping on street corners speed
bumps everywhere pornography billboards
all around our schools like there are
some problems there are some problems
like don't get me wrong I like LA I've
lived my entire life in LA but to
pretend that all the good things are you
really think that like Nashville doesn't
have any Symphony Orchestra you really
think Dallas doesn't have a Symphony
Orchestra you think there's no theatre
in Dallas yeah he's living in a really
the people on the coast aren't living
under rocks they're living in their own
bubbles and they've created a picture of
the rest of America that simply is not
true also worth noting really nasty to
chef boyardee the truth is that Chef
Boyardee was founded by an Italian
immigrant in Ohio in 1928 so I guess
it's red-state America
it was a tour Boyardee in 1924 he opened
his first restaurant in Cleveland and
people started asking him about his
spaghetti sauce and then he opened a
factory and moved production to Milton
Pennsylvania the US military
commissioned the company during World
War two for the production of army
rations so if you want to rip on Chef
Boyardee go for it man you want to rip
on a great American company founded by
an immigrant all you you do you blue
states already we will be back here a
little bit later two more hours of the
Ben Shapiro show later today so go
subscribe over at daily why otherwise we
will see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19